words matter
leveraging language can help us achieve
our communication goals join me as we
take a deep dive into wording
my name is Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
[Music]
today I am really excited to speak with
Jonah Berger Jonah is no stranger to
Stanford in the GSB he was an undergrad
here and then went on to the GSB to earn
his PhD he studied with one of our
previous guests chip Keith
Jonah is now a professor at Wharton a
consultant speaker and author of several
incredibly educational and fun books
including contagious why things catch on
the Catalyst how to change anyone's mind
an invisible influence the hidden forces
that shape Behavior I look forward to
discussing Jonah's research his writings
and his new book magic words welcome
Jonah and thanks for being here thanks
so much for having me yeah I'm super
excited for our conversation let's Jump
Right In
persuasion and influence are topics that
our listeners are thirsty to learn more
about in your book contagious why things
catch on you talk about what makes ideas
products and services become popular can
you distill down a few of the key tools
and tactics we can deploy in our
communication to help our ideas catch on
yeah so I think one of the the main
takeaways from that book is the power of
word of mouth and and how to use it so
whether we're making a presentation
whether we're selling a product we often
want people to support what we're doing
and sure what we do matters what we say
in that presentation or as marketers
what we say in an advertisement might
have an impact but we can have a much
larger impact if we can get other people
talking about our stuff if we can turn
customers into Advocates if we can turn
listeners and colleagues into supporters
if we can get them to share a message
not only will have more reach we reach a
broader set of people with that message
but we'll have much more impact and so
contagious is all about yes we're mouth
has power but how do we get it and so I
spent a long time studying the science
of Word of Mouth why people talk and why
people share about some things rather
than others we've looked at thousands of
pieces of online content tens of
thousands of Brands millions of
purchases around the United States and
around the world again and again we saw
the same six factors come up so in
contagious I talk about those factors
that drive word of mouth and drive
consumer behavior and more importantly
how we can leverage them to craft
contagious content how we can leverage
them to build messages and ideas and
products and presentations that will
spread and catch on certainly word of
mouth is powerful I I find myself
looking for things to watch and listen
to based on what my friends tell me and
products to buy what's one or two
techniques that can help Word of Mouth
develop sure the first big principle I
talk about is something called social
currency and the very simple idea there
is the better something makes us look
the more likely we are to talk about it
and share it so I talk about a story of
a bar for example sample hidden in a hot
dog restaurant like you walk down a
flight of stairs there's this hot dog
restaurant but in the corner of the room
is a phone booth and if you go into the
phone booth and you dial a number
someone will pick up the other line
they'll ask you to have a reservation if
you're lucky you have one the back of
that phone booth opens and you get let
into a secret bar called please don't
tell and what I love about that story is
first of all you know everyone everyone
can understand that story that sort of
hidden information really cool stuff
this place is hugely popular though
never advertised no sign on the street
no sign inside the restaurant how did
they get so much attention and they did
something really really simple they made
themselves a secret and if you think
about it there's a little secret about
Secrets if you think about the last time
someone told you something and they told
you not to tell anybody else what's the
first thing you probably did with that
information yeah I told somebody you
told somebody because having access to
information makes you look good makes
you look smart makes you look in the
know and so the idea of social currency
it's not just about Secrets but but it's
about we're more likely to share things
that make us look good then make us look
bad if I'm the first person to adopt a
new product or service if I have
information that not everyone else has
access to if something really good or
cool or exciting happens to me that
makes me look smart I'm more likely to
share it we talk about frequent flyer
status because it makes us look good to
our peers we talk about a new album
coming out because it shows we're ahead
of the curve and so the key insight
there is as Communications professionals
as individuals who want to get the word
out we often spend a lot of time
thinking about us our message our idea
we spend a lot less time thinking about
how the audience will look if they tell
people about it when I'm selling a
product maybe I make a perfect
advertisement and I want to make sure
that everyone will love the ad but I
don't think as much about okay well
someone sees that how are they going to
look if they tell their friends about it
because the better that's going to make
them look the more likely they'll be to
talk about it and share it wow I love
that Insight I want to know where that
bar is and I have to tell you that we
often speak on this podcast about
knowing your audience and taking time to
understand what they need and you're
adding an additional layer to that which
is it's not only what they need but how
does your message impact them and how
they feel how they look and that can
lead you to Greater success and and I
have to tell you you use that technique
on me as in preparation for this
interview you sent me a copy an advanced
copy of your new book magic words I read
it I told lots of people I know that
it's a great book and that they should
pre-order it as a result of having that
information and I have to share with you
some of my colleagues think I'm smarter
because of what I shared from your book
so you help make me look good and you
help me become an evangelist so thank
you for that and and I'd like to turn
our attention to your new book in that
book magic words you explore language in
its impact on behavior in fact I have a
quote here you write words suggest who's
in charge who's to blame and what it
means to engage in a particular action
consequently slight changes in the words
we use can have a big impact so my
question to you Jonah is what kind of
impact are you talking about and can you
provide one or two examples that
demonstrate that quote sure yeah so what
I find fascinating is we use words all
the time how we convince others hold
attention even to connect with our loved
ones we use words yet while we think a
lot about the general ideas we want to
communicate so maybe we get up in front
of an audience and our goal is to sell
them on a certain project we talk a lot
about how great the project is we think
a lot about the topic or the what we
want to communicate but we don't think a
lot about the how we communicate it the
specific words we use when sharing ideas
and unfortunately that's a mistake
because it turns out that subtle shifts
in language can have a huge impact on
everything from convincing clients and
holding attention to connecting with
loved ones in our lives and so by
understanding the science of language
the power of language how it works and
these types of magic words we can
increase our own impact whether that
means being more creative being more
invasive and holding attention and
captivating audiences in almost every
area of life we can use language to be
more effective you've got me sold on
that I I have often told people that
words matter we really have to think
about the language we use and we need to
make sure that that language is
appropriate for our audience and serves
a purpose for them and for us do you
have some examples you can share about
language use and how it can help us
achieve our communication goals sure the
book has six main types of words I like
Frameworks so I put them in a framework
called the speak framework that s p e a
c c because I couldn't come up with
something that had a K in it but that
stands for words that evoke similarity
posing questions is the p e is for
emotion A is for agency and identity one
of the C's is concreteness and one of
the C's is is confidence and so I'll
pick just one example from posing
questions I find questions really
fascinating because they do a lot of
work we often think about questions as
collecting information right getting us
an answer but they also have a big
impact on how people perceive Us and how
we see the world and perceive others
there's some nice research for example
on asking for advice and often we think
we shouldn't ask for advice why well
first of all we don't want to bother
someone right so if we're at the office
and we've got a problem that we're stuck
on we could ask a colleague we could ask
our boss but we don't want to bother
them they may not know the answer and
even worse or where they'll think less
of us they'll go well why why are you
asking me why couldn't you figure it out
yourself and so we often don't ask for
advice and not only is that bad because
we don't get the benefit of others
thoughts and advice and collect that
information but it's also bad because
we're missing out on a big opportunity
because when research examined asking
for advice and in a variety of
experiments and situations that looked
at how people were perceived when they
asked for advice versus dip not only
didn't they find that asking for advice
hurt made us look you know less smart
less knowledgeable have less expertise
in the space it actually had the exact
opposite effect asking for advice made
people look better not worse it made
others think they were more competent
smarter and more knowledgeable and the
reason why very simply is it takes
advantage of people's egocentrism
everyone thinks they have great advice
most of us like ourselves we like our
own advice we think we're pretty good
right and so when someone asks us for
advice we go oh that person must be
really smart because they're smart
enough for ask me for my opinion and so
asking for advice makes us look better
not worse and you could say well hold on
is that really a type of words that's
asking questions in general but there's
also research on the types of questions
to ask we often in conversation do sort
of introductory questions at the
beginning of this conversation you
probably said something like how are you
and I probably said something back like
fine how are you right and those are
good questions they're not bad they're
polite but when researchers looked at a
variety of different types of
conversations hundreds of different
types of conversations they found that a
particular type of question was
particularly impactful quite useful in
shaping how others perceive us it wasn't
these introductory three questions and
it wasn't kind of mimicry questions when
someone asked what are you having for
lunch blah blah blah what are you having
instead it's a type of questions called
follow-up questions and what follow-up
questions are is when someone says
something I enjoy this presentation
rather than saying oh I did as well
saying something like neat oh what part
did you like when someone says I had a
really tough day not just saying oh I'm
so sorry to hear that but oh what made
it so difficult tell me more there are
questions that follow up on whatever
someone said and show that you're
interested in collecting more
information because follow-up questions
do a few things first they show you're
paying attention being polite is easy
but they don't really signal that you're
paying attention but if you took the
time to listen to what someone said and
follow up with what they said it showed
you pay attention and you care you're
interested in learning more and not only
does that allow us to collect
information but it leaves people like us
more we show that we care about them and
what's going on with their lives and so
they like us more as a result and so
even something as simple as the
questions we ask and how we ask them can
have an important impact on how we're
perceived I really like this notion of
seeking advice and the benefits of doing
so because you as a teacher as a teacher
myself we often tell our students seek
feedback seek advice and many of them
are shy to do that because as you said
they're afraid it demonstrates weakness
or lowering their status and I love the
fact that research suggests it actually
bolsters it and clearly the types of
questions you're giving examples to not
only can help you getting input that
you're seeking but it demonstrates that
you're listening and interested in what
the other person says which is a great
way as you said a building trust in in
connecting
I'd love to ask you about one other
category of your speak framework and we
talk a lot on this podcast about
confidence confidence and communication
any guidance around language use and
confidence you can share yeah I think
all of us in our own lives can think
about someone that just exudes
confidence right that they have so much
Charisma whenever they speak other
people listen we can all think about
someone in our own lives like that and
if you look whether you look at gurus
you look at startup Founders you look at
leaders that are often thought about
charismatic they often have something
quite in common they often do the same
thing which is they speak with a great
deal of certainty and what do I mean by
that well if you look at what some of
these leaders do you know things aren't
just going to happen they're definitely
going to happen a course of action isn't
just a potentially good course of action
it's clearly the right course of action
everyone agrees this is unambiguous this
is essential it's irrefutable it's
guaranteed they use a lot of what some
people called definites they speak with
a great deal of certainty and not
surprisingly when someone speaks a
certainty when someone is so clearly
certain about what's true it's hard not
to listen to them because they seem so
convinced and I talk about five or six
different types of language links to
certainty but I'll pick one in
particular here and that's a set of
words and phrases called Hedges and if
you look at academics I'm I'm guilty of
this as much as anybody else we often do
a lot of hedging we say I think this is
the case this might be true this should
work it's a good possibility this will
probably happen the Hedge our language
we don't say this is the best solution
we say this might be the best solution
we indicate uncertainty in our language
and again sometimes we want to indicate
uncertain sometimes we want to be clear
that it's not certain what's going to
happen but unfortunately we often use
Hedges because they're a simple verbal
take it's easy to hedge and we often
unconsciously undermine our impact as a
result because if we're sitting there
saying I think such and such or this
might be true or this should happen or
might happen the audience is sitting
there going well if you're not even sure
it's going to happen yourself why should
I go along right if you're not even sure
this is a good solution if you're not
even sure this is going to work if
you're not even sure this is the best
course of action I'm much less likely to
be persuaded as a result and indeed many
experiments a colleague and I conducted
in this space as well as analysis we did
a field data shows that the more Hedges
we use the less persuaded other people
are and so I think this has a clear
implications ditch the hedges if we want
to persuade others ditch the hedges that
that doesn't mean we can't be
circumspect in our language that doesn't
mean we can't shrink the world of things
we're talking about but it's better to
be certain about a smaller set of things
than uncertain often about a larger set
of things well I sort of kind of think
that what you've said is really maybe a
little important I absolutely agree
hedging language can really undermine
what you're trying to do yet there are
as you point out times where I might
purposely want to lower my status to
invite others to speak imagine a boss
who says we should do this what do you
think versus I think we should do this
what do you think very very different so
when it comes down to confidence it
sounds like what's most important is
certainty and that's really really
helpful because nervous speakers people
who are new to positions and roles often
will use hedging language that can be
working against them definitely I'll
give you one more simple approach which
is the idea of turning past into
presence and I don't mean uh holiday
presence here so you know often when we
talk about something we use the past
tense oh I liked their food or they had
good food at a restaurant I thought the
job candidate did a very good job I
thought the resume was impressive we're
using the past tense that resume was
impressive notice in that situation we
could also use present tense I think
their resume is impressive I think the
food is good I think this destination is
a lot of fun and it turns out that when
we use present tense people think we're
much more confident or certain in what
we're saying and are more likely to be
persuaded as a result because past tense
often suggest something was true for a
particular person at a particular point
in time their resume was impressive
suggests that when I looked at it last
week I thought it was impressive that
doesn't mean it's still impressive that
doesn't mean you will find it impressive
but it suggests it was impressive to me
whereas if I say hey that resume is
impressive I'm making an assertion Not
only was it true when I looked at it but
it's going to be true for all people for
all time and because you're willing to
make that assertion people think you're
much more certain about what you're
saying and they're much more likely to
be persuaded as a result and so sure
hedging you know is one strategy so is
turning past into presence but I talk
about two or three others and it's all
about using language to convey certainty
I love turning pasts into present I
think that's really fascinating and in
fact it's going to change how I ask my
next question originally I was going to
say I often say but now I'm simply going
to say I say that attention is the most
precious commodity we have in the world
today yet gaining others attention is
often not enough to be successful in our
communication we need to be engaging
which I Define is sustaining people's
attention I know along with some of your
colleagues you recently published
research that looks into how language
particularly emotional language can help
us be engaging what did your research
find and how can we leverage your
findings to be more engaging in our
communication yeah so I love the way you
teed up that question and we've done
some work as to what gets attention so
things like looking at social media
posts for example and looking at what
drives engagement what leads people to
click on something or titles or
headlines ways to use email subject
lines to get people to open them often
words like you for example can be quite
powerful because they act as a stop sign
they say hey stop what you're doing this
is specific to you second person
pronouns like you suggest some things
personally around relevant and so we're
more likely to pay attention but as you
noted for most of us we're not just
trying to get people to open an email
trying to get people to read it we're
not just trying to get people to stop
scrolling on social media and see our
posts we're hoping they'll read it we're
not just hoping that someone begins to
pay attention to our presentation we're
hoping they stay tuned for the rest of
it and so one thing we wondered is well
how can we hold attention more
effectively how can we use language in
particular to hold attention and I think
this is an interesting question because
I think some of us think holding
attention is all about the topic if I'm
talking about celebrity gossip people
are going to pay attention if I'm
talking about some new technology or
Hollywood Blockbuster people pay
attention but if I'm talking about
climate change if I'm talking about tax
reform if I'm talking about school
budgeting it's going to be hard to get
people's attention not only get their
attention but hold it and so what we're
interested in is hey can we hold
people's attention even for these topics
that might not seem as engaging and so
what we did to do this actually is we
looked at tens of thousands of online
articles and we looked not only at
whether people looked at them read them
opened them look how far down they read
did they keep reading this content where
did they stop did they read a sentence
and then opt out and do something else
and we found a few things that are quite
interesting so first style can make up
for Content sure content's important
sure enough there are certain topics
that people tended to topics held their
attention more than others but even
controlling for that certain language
could hold attention for any topic and
so it's not just about what you're
talking about it's how you're talking
about it and second there were two main
buckets that we found one was types of
language that make it just easier to
keep paying attention concrete language
was one of these things I can touch a
table I can see a painting I can imagine
a cherry red convertible the word
beautiful is harder to see the word
strategy is harder to imagine concrete
language because it's easier to think
about is easier to process and holds our
attention better same with familiar
language the more familiar words we use
or even easier to process language
encourages attention but even
controlling for that as you noted we
also found emotional language was quite
impactful emotional language did a great
job of holding attention and it wasn't
just that any emotion worked or that
positive emotion helped maybe a negative
emotion hurt it was really the
Tendencies or association with
particular motion some emotions for
example tend to be relatively certain
other emotions tend to be more uncertain
an emotion like hope for example
suggests you know I hope that something
will happen but I'm not sure an emotion
like anxiety and anxious language says
we don't know what's going to happen and
so what we found is that the language
associated with uncertainty whether due
to emotional reasons or otherwise was
more likely to encourage people to keep
paying attention you know if you don't
know what's going to happen you stay
tuned to figure it out you keep reading
to figure out what's going to happen and
thinking about this I think of you
mentioned chip Heath and his great book
made to stick they talk about opening a
curiosity Gap yes where you you point
out you know something but you don't
know everything and to me that's a lot
of what uncertain motions is doing and
saying hey stay tuned to figure out the
answer and as a result it's holding your
attention you know many of us use
language in a way to try to demonstrate
our competence so we'll use big words
complex sentences remove emotion and
what I hear you saying is a lot of that
actually works against us when we're
trying to be engaged and compel people
to still listen to us and so the advice
to be concrete to build curiosity I
think is is really really helpful and I
challenge everybody to think about when
you're speaking what do you do with your
language to engage people because it
sounds to me like many of us are
actually subverting our own goal of
keeping people paying attention what I
found fascinating about working on this
book is there's just so many subtle
things we can do in almost every area of
our life to increase our impact if we're
trying to solve a problem for example
rather than think about what we should
do think about what we could do
literally switching one word from should
to could help think more broadly and
come up with more Creative Solutions
even we don't end up doing one of the
things we thought we could do helps us
think about a broader set of ideas and
makes us more creative and better at
solving problems if we're trying to get
someone to help us out rather than
asking them for help asking them to be a
helper makes them more likely to agree
to help us similarly when we're trying
to get someone to vote asking to be a
voter rather than asking to vote makes
them more likely to go along and put
both of these ideas under a strategy
called Turning actions into identities
sure voting is a nice thing sure helping
is a nice thing but what all of us
really want is to see ourselves
positively as smart as efficacious as
competent and so we engage in behaviors
that allow us to claim desired
identities and so if suddenly voting
becomes an opportunity to show that
we're a voter well now we're more likely
to do it if helping is an opportunity to
show I'm a helper much more likely to do
it the same is true on the opposite side
losing is bad but being a loser well
that's even worse cheating is bad but
being a cheater is even worse research
shows that if you ask students rather
than saying don't cheat you tell them
don't be a cheater they're much less
likely to cheat because now cheating
would show that they're claiming this
undesired identity and so when we want
to motivate others you know turn actions
into identities even when describing
ourselves and peers if you think about
it often we describe ourselves using an
adjective or again a verb we say I am
hard working well that's good but let me
say imagine I told you about two people
someone who runs and someone who is a
runner if you had to guess which of
those two people runs more often the
person who runs or who is a runner well
I would say based on what you've said is
a runner yeah right being a runner
suggests a stable trait it's not just
something that happens once in a while
it's who you are and so rather than
talking about yourself as hard working
talk about yourself as a hard worker
rather than talking about yourself as
creative you're a Creator or someone
else as a Creator rather than being
Innovative you're an innovator by
claiming these identities either
describing ourselves that way or others
that we want to be perceived favorably
it encourages them to see those things
as more stable traits and have people
think they're more like I can persist as
a result so it sounds like to me putting
ourselves in the role as a runner as uh
somebody who is a helper really helps
our audience see us as more engaged and
to be somebody who's more involved with
that I can imagine before we end I'd
like to ask you the same three questions
I ask everyone who joins me are you up
for that sounds great excellent if you
were to capture the best communication
advice you have ever received as a five
to seven word presentation slide title
what would it be I'll go with three
words understand your audience aha yes
so I'm in marketing so I get to cheat a
little bit so you know I've been at
Wharton now for I think over 15 years
and at a certain point once you get
tenure they ask you to teach the
marketing core and the main take home
from that course is be customer Centric
great marketing doesn't end with the
customer you don't make a product and
figure out how to sell it it starts by
understanding what products the
customers want or services and designing
those products same thing as a
communicator the better you understand
your audience whoever that audience is
the more effective you're going to be
that is a theme that has echoed many
times on this podcast and thank you for
adding to that chorus question two who
is a communicator that you admire and
why I don't think I have a specific
person in mind but I'm always amazed
when people can take complex topics and
ideas and make them simple so I was at
the doctor recently and I was dealing
with particular Doctor Who just made the
simplest things complex I had no idea
what they were talking about and then
similarly that same weekend I was at a
local Museum talking to someone about
butterflies and I know nothing about
butterflies our son is uh almost six
years old loves butterflies and they
were able to take the most complex
things about butterflies and make them
simple and so I think anyone that can
take a complex topic and make it simple
as a great communicator I agree I call
it accessibility we have to take these
complex topics and make them accessible
to lots of people and it is a true gift
in art even though there are are some
very specific tactics we can use
question number three what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe I think
going back to what we talked about
already you've got to start by
understanding your audience second
you've got to figure out a way to
communicate it simply but then I think
third you have to at the end of it drive
them to action I talk a lot about in my
last book The Catalyst whenever we're
trying to change someone's mind too
often we start by pushing by trying to
add more information persuade them facts
figures it's much better to identify the
barriers to change and mitigate them and
really think about how can we help
people get to where we wanted them to
get to in the first place on their own
asking the right questions that lead
them down a path rather than forcing
them down that way and so I think great
communicators are good at not just
telling their audiences what to do but
helping their audiences see that the
best way for the audience to reach what
they wanted to do is to do with the
Communicator was interested in having
them do in the first place I love that I
love that pull them in your direction
well Jonah thank you so much we all
benefit from what you have been able to
teach us or should I say thank you for
being a great teacher it's been
wonderful to learn from you and and to
have a chance to chat with you and I
wish you well on your book magic words
it is truly magical I've learned a lot
and as everybody listening in today is
heard it's changed my behavior
immediately thank you so much thanks so
much for having me
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn
[Music]
thank you